did this character really have to go and
why did they butcher his personality
like that no wonder everyone's so mad
spoilers for the witcher season two
ahead prior to its release on december
17th showrunner lauren schmidt hizrik
revealed that season 2 of the wisher had
learned from the mistakes of the first
season and would deliver a tv show
worthy of the white wolf this latest
season now available on netflix picks up
after the pyroclastic conclusion of
season 1 finally bringing geralt to
rivia and yennefer together in a
meaningful and almost binding way one of
the most pressing themes of this new
batch of episodes is family and
considering the interactions between the
main characters this is only likely to
grow in intensity over time in episode
two of season two geralt and siri find
themselves in a stronghold called
keramorin this essentially serves as a
capital for witchers and most of its
inhabitants have undergone the same
transformation process as geralt through
which regular humans can become capable
of combat against powerful beasts
returning to what is essentially his
homeland geralt comes across his mentor
vesemir as well as some of his brothers
in arms including a witcher named eskel
portrayed by basil einenbez
unfortunately for die hard fans of the
witcher video games and andre
sapkowski's books this episode's
approach to a fan favorite character had
them ready to unleash their own
destructive magic and profanity episode
2 appropriately titled karamorin sees
the newly introduced witcher eskel
quickly meet a horrific end when he's
transfigured into a monstrous tree
creature known as a lesson this was a
development some fans of the books did
not expect or appreciate but it was only
the beginning in an episode discussion
thread on the official subreddit for the
witcher franchise one user wrote they
could have just you know made one of the
other random witchers infected but nah
we gotta just kill off as gold for no
reason not before making him act like a
total douchebag first this elicited a
tremendous response from fans many of
whom with knowledge of the source
material were similarly disappointed by
such a popular character being killed
right away
i knew something
was wrong
i don't know what happened
one reddit user added what the actual
[ __ ] is this just going to freight
jazzical and completely get on source
material it was typically the more
dedicated witcher fans that felt
betrayed by the series decision to get
rid of eskel so quickly one user summed
up things by saying but killing off
eskel why anyone reading the books or
playing the games will feel awkward
knowing they just killed him off in half
an episode in the show seriously what a
way to completely
on a great first episode while much of
the fan disappointment over eskel's
character arc is centered on the fact
that a fan favorite character dies in
the very same episode introducing him
some viewers are similarly upset about
his change in personality compared to
his prior appearances in the witcher
books and video games one popular
twitter post about eskel's new
characterization includes a screenshot
of a document associated with the new
season of the witcher describing basil
item ben's version of eskel as a
particularly arrogant witcher who loves
sharing tales of his adventures and
celebrating them with women and wine
needless to say that isn't a
characterization most fans agreed with
whereas in prior appearances a set of
facial scars have been a prominent
component of his characterization they
found that the show quote heavily
downplaying his scarring should have
been a heads up
you're all right
i like the hell
one twitter user likewise expressed
their disappointment in how eskel was
handled by the tv series writing i knew
netflix would change things from the
book so i was prepared but eskel being a
mean womanizer who brought girls to kara
morin and through a party wasn't one of
them so while eskel may simply be a
short-lived companion of carol de rivias
to viewers unfamiliar with prior
versions of the witcher existing fans of
the character were unhappy with both the
character's new personality and his
death coming so soon after his
introduction check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]